voilà donc pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité de ce 1er mai dans une
dizaine de minutes nous parlerons rugby
à la veille de la finale du championnat
de france
mais d'abord place à l'automobile pour
notre page spéciale
claude cet accord imola en costume civil
cette fois je me suis changé à imola où
nous avons connu une première séance
d'essais plein d'émotions en effet l'un
des favoris nelson piquet tu as cassé
son véhicule il est blessé légèrement
des conclusions traumatisme crânien il
pourrait ne pas participer au grand prix
dimanche
lionel chamoulaud résume cette première
séance d'essais d'imola
l'image forte de cette première journée
en pleine vitesse alors qu'il vient de
réussir le meilleur tour nelson piquet
quitte la piste en tête à queue la
williams percute le mur violemment et
continue sa course dans l'herbe
image impressionnante inquiétude pour
pic est finalement le brésilien souffre
seulement d'un traumatisme crânien et de
contusions multiples aux jambes
bien sûr il n'est pas certain qu'il
puisse prendre le départ du grand prix
dimanche
autre moment fort la sortie de route de
bergues heure là pas trop de casse
heureusement le sable fin de la ferrari
joensson casse et fument l'huile se
répand sur la piste les voitures
s'arrêtent
de toute façon les commissaires décident
d'interrompre une nouvelle fois la
séance d'essai
la piste est trop glissante une séance
d'essai ou de nouveau les williams honda
ont été les plus rapides
piquette précède mansell troisième temps
encore un moteur honda remet avec à
lotus d'ayrton senna
au pays des ferrari les voitures rouges
sont en position d'attenté avec le
cinquième temps de bergues heures mais
petit étonnement alain prost n'a réussi
lui que le 9e chrono d'une séance
d'essai perturbé et un peu folle
encore une preuve la ligier de ginza ni
démenti but est à l'avant en tout cas
les ligier seront de retour
pour la première fois pour la saison 87
de formule 1 l'écurie ligier était
présente et c'est une manière d'exploit
guy ligier que d'avoir réussi à
présenter deux véhicules pour ce grand
prix d'imola
ces électrodes comme vous le savez après
nos problèmes avec fiat et alfa romeo
eh bien nous avons cherché un moqueur
cas motors megaton a été heureusement
disponible mais c'est vrai créé a
demandé trois semaines de travail
n'était joué nous avons coupé comme vous
le voyez ici mentir dollar à partir de
là et tout ça est nouveau complètement
sar avec combien de personnes est ce que
l'on monde ce genre de choses eh bien
nous avons fait avec 85 personnes et ça
représente 23 mille heures de travail
nuits et jours des pièces usées avec des
pièces ou vinet avec les supports moteur
avec les échappements avec les
entretoises de boîte avec tout ça et je
crois je peux dire aujourd'hui que
michel tétu bojan toute l'équipe ont
fait un travail extraordinaire et nous
sommes là et croire me croyez moi claude
j'étais triste de ne plus être là et
pour toute notre équipe je vous assure
c'est à et qui c'est un moteur allemand
bmw mais gâteront vous votre souhait
c'est que l'on retrouve un moteur
français tout à fait claude je crois que
si on veut regagner des grands prix à
jour la seule solution c'est de faire
notre moteur il n'y en a pas d'autres je
pense je pense que si nous commençons
notre moteur maintenant en 1989 je suis
sûr que nous pourrons regagner des
grands prix
très bien mais c'est ce que je souhaite
aux écuries françaises car il faut le
dire il n'y a pas que ligier en course
il ya aussi deux autres écuries
françaises
voyez le reportage de lionel chamoulaud
lancement d'une nouvelle formule un
premier essai raté deuxième essai raté
troisième essai la marche
clin d'oeil pour un baptême tout à fait
réussie philippe alliot sur la nouvelle
larousse est calme elle était ce matin
la meilleure voiture équipée d'un moteur
atmosphérique petit exploit pour une
débutante que de devancer tyrrell marges
et à gs dès sa première sortie même si
les turbos sont loin devant huit
secondes d'écart c'est bon commerce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il m'a là c'est
vraiment la série le matin et c'est un
des plus mauvais circuit et d'année pour
nos illustrations la lola elle c est
devant la lotus turbo de nakajima
philippe alliot réussi à contenir le
japonais dans les parties sinueuses
mais dans les parties droite la
puissance du turbo fait la différence en
tout cas mention bien pour aliot et la
lola elle sait seul détail qui restent à
régler décider du numéro la fédération
octroie le numéro 30
l'écurie tient à son numéro 76 celui de
la seine maritime à suivre aux équipes
françaises
autre moteur atmosphérique l'écurie à gs
pascal fabre et l'équipe de bons faron
continue de progresser et d'apprendre
cette saison trois français philippe
streiff chez tyrrell philippe alliot
chez lola elle c est pascal favreau chez
agf se battront pour le titre du
meilleur pilote atmosphérique pour le
trophée
jim clark
et on vient donc de voir la présence de
la mécanique de la france dans
l'automobile mais celui qui symbolise
sans doute le mieux la réussite
l'automobile française parce que l'un
pour le solde est sans doute le champion
le plus prestigieux pour les porter
actuellement et je vous ai rencontré
tout à l'heure vous aviez une sorte de
sérénité assez tranquille
la victoire est quasiment acquis
invitant des vrais maniaques et c'est
justement mon sac
votre réaliste on a une voiture qu'ils
mangent pas très bien on s'est tournés
en est serein ce qui concerne la
compétitivité de la voiture et la
fiabilité mais tout peut arriver ne
serait ce que le temps la pluie
peut arriver donc on sait qu une course
n'est jamais gagnée d'avancé on sait que
pour l'ensemble du championnat ça va
bien se passer
le président des cours
maintenant aussi la apaiser la colère
tout se passe bien et que préside
emballé tout se passe bien c'est très
difficile dans ces milieux
à beaucoup d'intérêts en jeu il ya
beaucoup de
les parties concernées les sponsors les
pilotes
la presse et publiques et bien entendu
la fédération
on n'est jamais
content on n'est jamais ensemble en plus
qu'a donc on essaye de trouver des
meilleur compromis possible est ce que
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire pour
l'instant
c'est une tâche à laquelle je ne serais
bien passé vous avez une âme de
syndicalistes n'ont pas du tout
justement mai
je crois qu'il fallait le faire parce
que c'est très important
bien entendu je suis plutôt en fin de
carrière pour des bus et de fait c'est
pas simplement pour moi c'est aussi
pourri
mais je crois que il ya des moments
quand on a vraiment envie de se faire
entendre du folk et affichant production
de twilight en profiter
alors maintenant beau but c'est de
rattraper stewarts ah oui ça contre le
mans
dépassés oui parce que
ensuite cette femme maintenant et comme
j'ai pas vraiment l'intention d'arrêter
courir en 88
je crois que cette année de l'année
prochaine qui aura été des chances de
pouvoir dépasser un poste on peut voir
maintenant grâce à lionel chamoulaud un
petit peu votre carrière et puis
en comparaison avec jacques ici voir ce
qu'il vous reste à faire pour le
dépasser et petits peut-être pour
attraper un autre coureur encore plus
prestigieux
ce geste prost l'a connu 26 fois alain
prost en chiffres c'est 106 grand prix
disputé 26 victoires 49 podium soixante
et une course terminer dans les six
premiers et deux titres de champion du
monde
la course aux records est engagée prost
est un homme de chiffres et toute son
énergie son talent sont axées vers ce
but il possède déjà le fameux jim clark
qui sur lotus entre 1962 et 1968 à
remporter 25 succès et a été sacré deux
fois champion du monde il devance
également l'une de ses idoles
niki lauda 25 victoires pour l'ancien
coéquipier de prost mais l'autrichien a
été couronné trois fois champion du
monde en 75 77 et 81 4 mai alain par
chiffres interposés court encore après
son autre idole jackie stewart entre
1965 et 1973
l'écossé a gagné 27 fois une fois de
plus que prost jackie stewart a
également remporté trois titres de
champion du monde
qui dès cette saison prof peut égaler ou
même dépasser et stewards
il devra alors s'attaquer peut-être à un
autre monument juan manuel fangio pour
être le pilote absolue fangio en 51
grand prix à gagner 24 fois il a été
couronné champion du monde à cinq
reprises en 51 et de 54 à 57 5 titres
cela paraît aujourd'hui inaccessible
mais peut-être pas pour alain prost
donc le bulletin cefrio quand même c'est
encore mieux que steve martin j'ai
jamais pensé vraiment je pense que
si blanc se croit très difficile saint
cricq de toujours penser que l'épisode
jeunes de notre génération des projets
j'en ai à voir si ça veut dire vous
arrêterez avant d'en être facile gagné
cette année on sait jamais ce qui alors
il y a quatre autres coureurs français
pilote automobile français dans la
course et la deuxième représentation
rapport aux italiens vous êtes donc cinq
pilotes français alors on a décidé de
faire une photo de famille compte
terminer cette édition spéciale
alors on va rejoindre venez les
rejoindre à la fin ce qui pourrait alors
écoutez vous les connaissez pratiquement
tout ce qu'on voulait représenter rené
arnoux de chez ligier philippe lalliot
qui démarre une saison avec la rousse
calmels a fait un bon temps aujourd'hui
et puis à ses côtés alors à l'excellent
bouche on à philippe secrète chez
tyrrell dit pascal fabriqués chez ag as
voilà la photo de famille c'est sur
cette image que je vais vous quittez en
souhaitant bonne chance 5 du pilote
automobile français et en les remerciant
pour le spectacle qui nous donne croyez
moi ici on est fortement impressionné à
bientôt
merci messieurs rendez vous donc
dimanche sur le circuit d'imola ce week
end